welcome to the across the spoiler verse
podcast I'm your host Paul joined across
the spoiler verse by my man Greg Alba
out in the US how's it going Greg baby
what's happening I'm doing good baby but
at the same time I'm wondering why are
we called across the spoiler verse
what's what happened in real spoilers my
name is being officially removed from
the title already second episode
so what happened was uh me and Greg we
came up with the podcast idea we thought
you know I wrote a channel called heavy
spoilers Greg runs one called real
rejects we'll combine it yeah we'll make
real spoilers we put 10 seconds thought
into it we thought we've got a banger
here it explains it all turns out though
yeah there's another podcast out there
called real spoilers those guys have
been doing it for about 10 years uh over
700 episodes so they might have a bit on
us you know we did the first one
um but they so what happened was I I
didn't see this but they tweeted us
saying hey guys we've uh We've we've run
the same podcast with the same name and
uh do you mind just changing it I didn't
see it and then a couple of days later I
start getting bombarded with stuff like
thief and uh there was one one said um
you oh so you stole a podcast name and
thought people wouldn't know it's her
and I was like we literally put like 10
seconds thought into this and entire
thing I I I wasn't really trying to
steal anything but the guy we so he
spoke to him
um Kevin really nice guy there totally
understood it he was like you know what
we've seen it and we could we didn't
think it stole it we could see how you
had to organically come up with um real
spoilers on your own so we'll let you
off we'll call we'll call the guys off
uh they'll stop tweeting you and yeah
just come up with a new name you've got
48 hours so the new name is the real
real spoilers no it's uh yeah
across the spoiler verse um we we did
start searching lots of different names
that we tried spoiler cast there was
hundreds of ones called that um
heavy spoilers there was even heavy
Spoilers Podcast out there which uh I'll
find them and I'll kill them
someone suggested heavy Rejects and I
was like that sounds like we're talking
about overweight people and I don't know
if you want it
that's like an in sales podcast app
which do turn over a lot of money to be
fair but yeah podcasting they're
difficult to come up with I I know that
there's two now two observations out
there so today that Rob liefeld had
posted one his new podcast called
observations and Robert Maya Bennett's
had one for for years and years so
they're probably gonna be duking it out
on Twitter next um but yeah we just
thought what's the most recent thing we
can say that it's so recent no one could
have possibly have made a podcast about
yet so it was across the spoiler there
so we're gonna bring new spoilers every
single week um from across the the
Atlantic Ocean we've got the US and the
UK covered and that's the name change so
if anyone messages us saying you stole
across the spoiler verse I I'm I tell
you you're dead I've got I've got the
money I've got the contacts I've got the
resources you are dead so don't bloody
do it no lovely speaking to those guys
at real spoilers go check them out
um yeah they dealt with it really well
and it wasn't there's been some
companies that I've dealt with Greg will
tell you a message saying hey guys your
thumbnail looks a bit similar to a one I
did do you mind just changing it and it
got Liars involved and were instantly on
the case and they're yeah we won't go
who into who that is but it's quite a
big Channel and it was quite funny uh it
doesn't take a lot of fun to figure out
who it is it's pretty easy to narrow it
down if you guys want I mean we could
have generated more numbers on this
podcast if we just create a drama with
real spoilers if we were full I don't
want to go
I don't want to go on a runt against any
screen sort of YouTube channels
um so yeah the we'll just leave it at
that and not talk about anything else
I'm already in trouble I can hear the
lawyers on the phone right now
well yeah I mean we should hop into
across the spoiler verse today though
because looking over our list and Paul
my job today everyone listening I'm
gonna make sure we stay on track we read
your feedback we got a lot of great
comments we got a lot of love but we
heard the two people who were like a
little bit too much Meandering and we
feel it too so we're gonna we're gonna
make sure we are on track today and
we're gonna have video chapters this
time aren't we Paul yeah definitely and
go to all Clips Channel heavy spoilers
Clips where we'll be posting little
segments from the podcast just talking
on certain topics you might want to just
skip over all the the two hours of
Meandering and rambling about uh what
we've been up to this week uh so yeah
that'll make sure you head over there as
well yeah so today uh we are going to be
talking about with James Cameron
apparently Terminator Never Dies Never
Dies we got John Wick resurrected
already uh we got Deadpool 3 news we
gotta talk about uh it was specifically
regarding the writer strike and him
improvising it's going to be ADR the
movie and then we have uh of course
Spider-Man across the spider-verse
fitting we're gonna do a spoiler
discussion of it and uh we discussed
beforehand what we wanted to talk about
so yeah uh guys leave a like on this
video that helps us out in the algorithm
and both Paul and I we agreed right away
without hesitation that the first thing
we wanted to talk about would be the
Terminator sequel so Paul why don't you
kick us off what is going on with the
Terminator sequel my friend James
Cameron's in the news
he's announced that he is he was working
on a new script for it but he wants to
see what happens with AI and go from
there it's like come on mate what just
write it like AI you can pretty much
predict where it's going to go anyway
it's gonna steal everyone
maybe that's what he meant I'm just
seeing where AI goes and if I can hand
it off to that then uh I don't need to
do any work but yeah just like you can
kind of predict where it's going to go
we're not we're probably not going to
get nukes coming in I think uh AI is
probably just gonna
steal our all our jobs everything we
love doing like drawing writing scripts
you know things people enjoy doing
creatively that's going to get taken
away so yeah James just uh just get to
it it might be the right last script
ever written in Hollywood
but you know what this entire movie kind
of hinges for me personally on whether
John Connor's gonna be in it because our
re-watch dark fate the other week I've
been doing a Terminator retrospective on
the channel doing um the first film the
breakdown of that's coming up very soon
and I thought you know what I'm just I'm
just gonna watch dark fate didn't like
it at the time I thought times you know
it heals all wounds we'll see what
happens with it
straight away as soon as they kill John
Connor I was like yeah
so I I don't just James Cameron yeah he
obviously can make good movies big ones
as well he makes massive events which
Avatar's just shown but I don't know if
we need another one we really don't
it's a franchise that just never seems
to go away and Terminator 2 is is
Terminator 2 and one of your favorite
movies of all it fluctuates for me as
definitely one of the most influential
in my life and that and the Matrix are
I'm constantly fluctuating between which
one is my all-time favorite movie yeah
so Terminator two and you know James
there was a time where you said James
Cameron and Terminator that meant good
news where he endorsed Terminator 3
arrives in the machines and dust them
all yeah uh no Genesis it was just
Genesis and then I went like okay this
must be great and then it wasn't and and
then he was obviously involved with the
producing and the story development and
did a whole like q a with Tim Miller
before they even started filming for
dark fate so I was like here we go
Terminator back on track and then the
first 10 minutes I was like what is this
movie you're kind of breaking my heart
here and now to hear he's writing it and
then I'm kind of getting a bit of like a
Season of the Witch vibe following
franchise if he's not focused on even
the things to do like a bunch of
Terminator movies that are about a
terminator and robots and stuff and then
to at least present how he wants to go
about it with this AI angle and not
really focus on the machines
I don't know it sounds like a completely
different franchise it sounds more akin
to when Ridley Scott was like I'm doing
an Alien prequel and then it wasn't an
Alien prequel it was Prometheus and he
wanted to just keep it like that so it
just doesn't even sound like it's going
to be a Terminator uh film to me you
know like you need certain earmarks of
it but it's James Cameron so we'll see
how it goes right the problem is with
all the Terminator stuff is that every
sequel after T2 is kind of doing its own
thing like Terminator 3
Judgment Day is happening mate you
didn't avoid it salvation we're in the
future War okay baby I'm down with that
Genesis no let's go back back to what
originally worked um but we're gonna
change things up from that original
movie and go in a slightly different
direction and then dark fate as well
that's just this whole other reboot
thing that what my big problem with dark
fate was re-watching it is that they
crap so much over those first two films
but they also rely so heavily on them so
all the good moments in them are with
Arnie and Linda Hamilton it's like we
need we this is that's the past get rid
of it it's rubbish you want these new
people that you can't even remember the
names of I think it was Danny and Grace
it was the character so to be fair I can
remember the names of them
um but it's like get rid of those old
ones but also build the plot heavily
around them they have to be in every
scene once Linda Hamilton shows up we
need an old character in every scene so
it's kind of like it's a very misguided
and it's almost
just rehashing the elements of the past
and after grabbing all over them and
when I was watching it I was thinking
why would I invest in this person when
10 years down the line another director
could come along and go well Danny she's
gonna get killed in the first five
minutes so you don't care anymore so
it's just kind of it just kills the
whole franchise for me I mean John
Connor everything was built around him
and like I said if James Cameron focuses
that next movie around John Connor we'll
see how I do you know we'll see if uh
get on board with it but
I just don't have faith in the guy I
think it'll be a totally different movie
named Terminator like you said sort of a
Prometheus thing like it's funny when
you reminded me of the dark fade
comparison of of the with the experience
of that because you covered Alien 3 on
your channel recently this channel right
here you covered Alien 3 and how they
killed off
um uh Hicks and Newt at the very top of
that film and that was such a blow
because that was uh that Alien 3 came
out not like there's definitely not a
gap like how there was between T2 and
dark fade and dark fade was being
pitched as the real Terminator three and
I was thinking if if that really did
come if that dark fate did come out like
shortly after Terminator two can you
imagine just how much more pissed off
people would be about it but at the same
time you know I was thinking uh Arnold
he's not going to uh he has stated that
he doesn't want to return like he really
believes good audience doesn't care for
him to return he just wants to do five
seasons of Fubar and then leave it at
that and the other thing that was really
beloved even though it wasn't a hit the
the one that was most beloved was
actually the Sarah Connor Chronicles and
I haven't seen any of that but I know
it's got a really good fan have you seen
it is that good because if it was the
first season it was good all right sweet
well there's a there's a hope for
Terminator to be still succeed without
Arnie yeah awesome I think they should
get John Connor for it uh not junk I
know what the hell John Cena John Cena
very similar to John Connor but yeah get
John Cena to play the Terminator he's
got the build he can pull off the comedy
stuff he can pull off the threatening
stuff get the guys the Terminator oh and
he's not gonna do it John Cena's my man
taking him now
wacky turbinator that would be funny
they'll uh fast ax him up well yeah well
we got another sequel to talk about
don't we Paul I'm keeping us on track
today Paul we got ourselves we got
ourselves to return the resurrection of
John Wick in John Wick five something
that I personally uh did not really want
and
I I was I I feel like there was a way to
make this news exciting for even a fan
fans like ourselves if they waited a
while instead of going nope we're
working on it and you know Keanu Reeves
I was at a q a with him where he really
said that he stated that the only reason
he one of the main reasons he returns so
that way John Wick could die he wanted
John Wick to die and to see the new five
with David Leach being like no no not
David Lee Chad's the helski yeah chance
the hells shots the helski saying that
yeah I'm open-minded if something does
come to mind but Lionsgate does seem to
be pushing it
um you've been covering John Wick a lot
on your channel were you at all excited
about this Paul
I was a bit annoyed because I don't see
what else they can do with the character
I think once you have the death story
that's it like in chapter five then be
and he comes back he takes down the high
table again and then dies at the end
that could be one scenario or he comes
back
takes down the high table again and then
lives at the end and they just keep
churning out these sequels forever
personally I don't think they're gonna
top the ending of John Wick 4 in terms
of giving the character a proper send
off I think it's the same with Iron Man
in the MCU I think Captain America going
off with Peggy Carter those things
you're not gonna get better than them so
don't attempt it just leave it don't
terminate her it don't try and dark
fight everything and give you a crazy
take on stuff on how he comes back just
leave it out of that yeah but obviously
people want to see the franchise keep
going but as soon as I saw the headline
I just thought cash grab Lion's gay
they're like
do you guys have you did talk about
doing a fifth film at one point which
they did and then they decided that they
didn't really have enough ideas for it
and that four would be the perfect place
to say goodbye just kill him off uh so
yeah personally I think they should have
stopped there but Hollywood is Hollywood
and sequels are one thing that
constantly generate money and with the
last movie making so much they just
can't leave it alone they can't leave
the dog alone you know the entire you
know what the entire saying of the
franchise is just leave John Wick alone
that happens at several points I'll
re-watch them the characters are like
just don't go after John and people keep
going after him and it just leads to
chaos and everything come crumbling down
so yeah maybe they should learn from the
lessons of the film and just leave the
guy alone and let him die please
is getting much older now he is he is
much older it's as great as the guy ages
yeah I am concerned for him and it's it
it has to reach some whole new fantasy
level I feel like he's just going to
become the actual Boogeyman by this
point he's just going to evolve into the
real boogeyman as well
I said when the movie released that I
did a little joke tweet that he could be
in hell and he's gonna fight his way
because the the film's very much a
metaphor for Dante's Inferno and he
could fight his way through hell get to
God get to heaven get back with his wife
it'd be like some crazy I was taking the
mick obviously I don't think they should
do that it kind of seems like that's
yeah kind of cool if it was like an
anime that's not a bad idea yeah as much
as you're making a joke I'm like there's
an anime version of this that would be
pretty [__] sweet to watch like a try
someone's put yeah right now someone's
putting that prompt into check GPT but
generate a script write me a script for
John Wick I'm sure there's there's
they're trying to figure out something
is there anything within the John wicker
verse that they're developing I'm I'm
looking forward to the Continental
personally even though we haven't seen
much about it I'm curious to see if they
are able to bring the action uh if
they're able to replicate the kind of
action style from the films onto TV that
I feel like they would have a really big
hit on their hands if they if they can
do that uh but the the ballerina one as
much as I like Anna De armas
um
I feel like if you don't have Chads to
helski directing it it it just doesn't
excite me uh for some reason yeah if
you're the director of the ballerina let
me let me do some little Tech work here
you Google and I'll talk over the top
and get people distracted to make them
keep hanging on the retention levels
gonna stay high so yeah I totally agree
who was it sorry Len Wiseman
well yeah I've heard that name before
um
bloody hell Total Recall Total Recall
remake uh no never seen actually to be
fair might be great
yeah I've never seen it either yeah so
do you wanna you know the franchise
might be dead by the time they get to
John Wick 5 if the continental and the
ballerina on the perform uh let's see
though they might they might Disney plus
it you know what I mean where you just
completely kill all the Goodwill for
your franchised with TV shows and
spin-offs and they get to the point when
the movies come out people are like I
don't know if I'm not interested anymore
I feel like what would be excited is
that they announced the Donnie Yen movie
if they did that or whatever if they'd a
cane film if they did something about
him yeah like a blind Warrior uh and
living in this world that would excite
me that would excitement
yeah do that as John Wick five just call
it John MC5 Kane
yeah if there's like a reward out on his
head for some stupid reason or if they
got all the bad guys who survived
throughout the franchise and you put
them in one big Suicide Squad we were
together or something yeah there's a way
to do it where you bring there's a way
to keep the franchise alive if they
wanted to because the world is so big
um but yeah I think I don't feel like
you need to bring back Keanu Reeves who
has spoken like four words although he
is like when he is doing the axes he
might not be the best with the delivery
he might not be but when he is doing the
action I feel like no one gets the body
language and the the rage spewing from
his facial features and the whole
demeanor uh as well as Keanu Reeves does
there's such a captivating part of
watching him it's more than just
watching him do fight scenes and there
is a such a great performance within
there's a little emotion he's he's
permeating through the screen when he's
doing it and that's the hard thing to
replicate it's like I noticed that when
I watched it really stood out to me with
John Wick 3 when him and Halle Berry
were having their big fight scene
because Halle Berry feels very
choreographed like it feels like an
actor who's choreographed and not really
much of the performances in there
whereas uh I mean she's doing good she's
moving great uh but I mean then when
they cut to Keanu there's like freaking
struggle that he's got going on at all
times and that's that's what I think
helps you stay on board without it
becoming exactly Fast and Furious is his
performance so there is strength to it
at the same time I feel like you can't
carry this on without him but Paul's son
Paul do you have more to say about this
I do yeah just speaking of Halle Berry
there's obviously lots of Side
characters in the franchise that never
really got send-offs either you had
common uh Ruby Rose Holly Barry's
another one I mean they can bring the a
lot of those kind of ended on
Cliffhangers as well the common one
especially was like he stabbed him in
the gut as a profession oh was it in the
heart he stabbed him somewhere as a
professional courtesy and then was like
I'll leave you alive and I'll see you
Leia and then Ruby Rose who was like
I'll be seeing you and she did the same
thing or so something like that and
these characters you know you got the
teas that they were going to come back
at some point and I always thought
they're going to show up in three and I
thought they were going to show up in
four but they never showed up so maybe
in five we'll fight we'll bring everyone
back we'll avenge is it if it said it is
The Avengers
the why didn't they come back you would
think they would have especially when
they set them up to come back yeah and
they never actually do that is a very
fascinating question especially when the
bounties
that's why we're getting five
we're the first one to dig his body out
from the grave it will be the one yeah
they really should just go Supernatural
with it I would be fine with it I I
personally would be fine if they just
went gung-ho Supernatural especially
with all its religious tones and
everything you were talking about so
yeah but Paul Paul Paul we have
ourselves
some fascinating Deadpool 3 News
um which I've feel very bad for them
because this should be the Epic this
should be so epic and what be
even though the script is locked for
this
and even though they are going to be
starting to film it we have a writer
strike going on and a rider strike
allowing no one to do any rewrites on
this including guild member Ryan
Reynolds and due to him being a writer
he cannot actually improvise during this
film of it and it's creating a whole
bunch of controversy because can you
stop that man from improvising what will
you do when they've they've have some
workarounds of what they can possibly do
which is you know the whole he's got a
mask on so we can just ADR everything if
he wanted to
but still I'm like I I don't know man I
think that there's more to it than just
having to worry about because I know a
lot of people have already covered this
topic and I think there's a lot of
people who are already saying that it's
fine he can he's got a mask on so he
could just ADR but there's a lot of
times where he doesn't have a mask on
and he's improvising that's one of the
funniest moments with him and there's so
much more to it than just his improv
lines like there's there's constant
rewriting that's happening and
constantly having to figure out and
retool reshaping while you're on set and
try to figure out scenes and this has to
be great and you know especially with
Hugh Jackman returning uh does this
provide any bit of calmness in your soul
knowing he can just do ADR later on and
is there any other concerns about what's
going on with Deadpool 3 for you
I would just get the script and go do
you guys know what lines are in this and
when they say no just go
rip it up explode it and then just go
well I it's all up here and whatever
stays on camera right now is exactly
what's in that script no so it's very
difficult for him I would I would never
actually think that improvising would be
classed as writing for some reason I
don't know why but obviously I'm I'm a
novice I don't really know the ins and
outs of this I don't know what the all
of the ins and outs of the strike are
either
um and it's kind of it's it is a strange
thing but luckily as you mentioned he is
a character that has a mask and you can
go back and watch those early Deadpool
movies and I can tell you you can see
some things that might have been made up
in ADR as you called it before ADR the
movie I think it's gonna work out fine
for this film they obviously have the
bare basic structure of the plot I doubt
that's gonna change or they're gonna
need it too and they're just gonna
you know show a photo show like a
shoulder shot of Hugh Jackman with his
back and Ryan Reynolds is just standing
there and they'll just animate the mouth
moving along with whatever he says in
the booth
yeah it's
yeah okay just to just to throw a little
bit of gasoline on the fire here of some
people who don't is especially when you
got actors like Ryan Reynolds and Hugh
Jackman who already display
that they like to improvise together you
know and I and I don't know if the rules
mean Ryan Reynolds because he is a
screenwriter because he's one of the
credited screenwriters for Deadpool 2 so
he's a guild member
and I I'm assuming he worked on the
script for Deadpool 3 as well
I don't know if that means you know Hugh
Jackman is allowed to improvise but Ryan
Reynolds can't improvise but a few
jackridge improvising you know like Ryan
Reynolds can't stick to the script then
if Hugh Jackman's improvising and a big
part of the appeal that I think for Hugh
Jackman as well was to lean into the
comedy and do and do a lot more of that
kind of fun sensibilities
and you know a lot of times when you got
these scenes and especially like
character scenes so much of the time you
hear the behind the scenes of when these
characters these actors are working
together it's like oh we couldn't figure
the scene out so we had to like sit down
we met up in our trailer and we worked
it out and we were figuring it out and
then we rewrote it and then and then
that's what we filmed it ended up making
I hear that story constantly and I and
and so a lot of people are thinking
about Ryan Reynolds not being able to
improvise but you're by by proxies
you're also limiting you know Hugh
Jackman from being able to do that as
well because you might have a good
script you might have a like a solid
script on hand but once you actually
start doing the scene especially for a
comedy you start going actually this
isn't that funny and so much of the
comedy within because one thing Hugh
Jackman said was he was really drawn to
it being a comedy and him getting a
chance to Showcase this like he was
referencing the movie 48 Hours having a
bit of that road trip buddy kind of
Comedy Vibe and if and now Hugh
Jackman's not going to be able to do
that as well so it's more than than just
Ryan Reynolds there's a whole ensemble
of people who they'd rely on to be able
to you know come up with [__] while
they're rolling the camera so well I
think the movie will be fine I worry
that the movie won't be as great as
people may hope for it to be do you have
thoughts
yeah I just wish they would end the
strike or not the right as end this
strike I just wish that their Studios
would see how much this is going to
damage their films and their brands by
just robbing to basically screenwriters
of some of the benefits that have made
the job bearable for them in the past
and although there's people out there
who are like well all those woke movies
that will not be getting any more work
movies but any you know the stuff you
like there as well it's not just a well
the shows I don't like all those writers
on strike they don't deserve to get paid
it's not that sort of thing it's every
single writer who's come together for
this so everything every single series
you like every single movie that you
like they're getting affected as well
you like top gun Maverick I bloody like
top gun Maverick stuff like that would
be affected you see what I'm saying so
you know you've got even if you don't
like some of the shows you've got to
kind of come together and realize that
this is gonna damage the industry across
the board and the stuff you like as well
that's gonna be hit by it is two so I
just wish this the studios would realize
like we are very much we rely on these
guys quite a lot and there's even been
some execs who've come out and said
little things like Amy Pascal she
announced that there's a new Spider-Man
4 coming that's been delayed because of
the writers strike and
she even she's like we're ready when she
said something weird like we are ready
when they are ready to accept or
something like that I'm Miss quoting it
but the point is that they know that
they rely on these guys and there's so
much stuff getting delayed especially
after the pandemic as well it's kind of
like can you not just you know give
these guys a bit extra for all the work
they do yes some of them write woke
shows that everyone hates we'll get you
could get you guys who don't like those
shows we understand but you have to
realize that it's just gonna affect
everything very badly and the longer it
drags out the worse it is Ryan bloody
Reynolds can't improvise on set you see
what I'm saying just let the guy
improvise please let's have some wiggle
room here yeah because then that's where
I don't they haven't even clarified if
he's not allowed to improvise on set
because do you remember when the the
writer strike was happening it was like
15 years ago when the talk show hosts
were still doing the shows but they
couldn't have their writers conducting
any of it the the the the talk show
hosts like he's part of the guild
exactly they're part of the guild and
yet they were able to still do their
shows and they're technically doing
these bits you know with the audience or
whatever where they are improvising the
whole time and it's still there so I'm
like okay but what is the rule here is
is it completely different for a talk
show when they're headed their credit is
like you know one of the head writers of
the series as well so I don't know it's
it's sad and then if we get the SAG
strike going on too then expect massive
I think I think that would actually help
the SAG strike weirdly because if the
sax I mean of course it would help for
for the actors who deserve to have
um you know everything that they're
asking for at the I'm not I don't really
know much about I'm just saying that to
be not I don't really know what they're
asking for uh but the but but that I
think would create a a wave as well
something that would be like repulsive
and push things forward where we're like
all right we really need to get [__]
together because now we don't have our
actors and writers and if they can solve
something with their what I've heard is
that if they solve it with their actors
if the sack strike does happen that
could really help out with what they
want to solve with the Riders as well so
it could be like a two-fold like
dramatic effect to lead everything in a
positive direction overall yeah just get
to a point where everyone wins you know
you don't have to give in to every
demand just work with those guys trying
you know explain why stuff's the way it
is now
work with work just work it out just
come together please I want what's best
for everyone
um and I hope those guys get what they
deserve does that you deserve a lot you
don't realize how much writing goes into
this stuff
yeah yeah and in the constant writing
the constant before you know there'll be
an editor strike and nothing will be
happening
uh well Paul we've made it to the point
where I'm just gonna listen to you for
30 minutes now the across the spider
versus spoiler time we're going to talk
spoilers for across the spider verse
Paul has collectively gathered 400 000
views off his spider-verse videos at the
time of recording this and so everyone's
just going to want to hear what you've
got to say I did like a three-hour talk
on this channel yesterday so I'm ready
to just listen to you Paul I didn't want
to I didn't want to like watch your
video because when it was three hours
but I also didn't want you to influence
what I was gonna say but I absolutely
loved it I thought it was you know I
thought it started off slow
um so we begin basically with Gwen
telling her story you know the the first
film kind of had that every time a
Spider-Man was introduced it was like
here we go again one more time and they
went through you know a comic book
origin for themselves how they came to
be what makes them different and so on
Gwen sort of got a lot more of a fleshed
out one for this film and we start off
in her Universe going through what
happened with her and Peter
um and then that kind of brought in the
vulture From Another Universe and I was
a bit like you know this is okay but
it's not really
a blowing my mind is uh you know I I
spoke to you you saw way before me and
you were like this is the greatest movie
I've ever seen there love it 10 stars
out at 20. and um
50 50 which is the highest score you've
ever given anything which is why it was
the best you see I'm working backwards
yeah I messed up but I'm keeping it
going
um so yeah the the um the opening and
then when it jumped to Miles as well I
was kind of like you know he was doing
stuff with his spot I thought it was
okay the the parents teacher meeting I
think it's called I thought was that was
okay and then I think once every once we
hit the spiders aside actually you know
once we hit mom button I think that's
when it really starts to pick up
um obviously that comes off the back of
the cameos which we'll spoil now so the
spot goes into the Multiverse
he comes across um Mrs Chen from the uh
the Venom verse what did you think when
you saw that because I had it spoiled so
I didn't I knew it was coming but I I
thought it was I thought it was funny
um yeah I I was spoiled for me that they
did go visit it so it was a lot of them
weren't most most of the cameos were not
spoiled for me uh but the Mrs Chen one
was fun and it it does
I didn't really think of until right now
this very moment I didn't think about
what it's just like okay so the Venom
universe is just its own it's like
completely separate universe as well so
they could just have a separate spot I
guess my mind is now starting to go down
that path of oh so they might just have
a completely different Spider-Man that
might not be the other Spider-Mans in
this movie just really helped solidify
that fact huh Robert Patton's in it
oh yeah that would be great yeah they
might as well
that baby they're protecting spoilers
for two weeks yeah yeah yeah so yeah
what was your favorite of the ones that
they uh that they went to
the Lego yeah I really like the Lego one
with uh Jay Jonah Jameson and the
newspaper that said doc Ox still at
large because I'm sure I might be
misremembering this but I'm sure I had
that newspaper Lego set where it had
like a little one of those tiny little
squares with a print on that you can
stick on the wall and I'm sure it had
doc Ox still at large So Not only was it
a reference to Spider-Man 2 because
that's where that newspaper pops up but
it was also reference to the Lego
Spider-Man 2 stuff I don't want to get I
don't want to get called out in case
someone's like that set never existed
actually and you're a fake for lying
about it but I'm sure it was and when I
seen that I was like I've seen that
somewhere before might have been at my
friend Ricky's house or something but
I've I've experienced that in real life
so and obviously Jay Jonah Jameson was
over the top and with JK Simmons voicing
him the guy popped up throughout this
the film at numerous points in the
background and I think he was in Gwen's
world as well
yes yes yes you hear him on the
television did you hear about uh who
created that Lego world and how they how
Lord and Chris Miller got that they
didn't know oh wow I mean I don't know
the full ins and outs details
um it's it's now been like a lot of
people are now talking about it uh but
McCoy was talking with uh Lord and
Miller at the screening that we were at
and they were telling him about how it
was there was like a 14 year old boy who
they saw created it he has his own
YouTube channel actually and so they
actually had to hit him up they caught
and texted him because they wanted him
to be the one who created and they he
what you're watching is his fortunate
boys creation who had to balance
creating this while also doing school
work and all these things so yeah some
like little kids dream literally getting
it actually plucked into the movie
itself which is pretty freaking sweet
that's pretty awesome uh I'm just
imagining like Javier it's showing up to
the kids house at like 2 A.M being like
what is this set film tomorrow
it was the audio of Jay Jonah repurposed
from one of the spider I couldn't tell
if it was new audio that JK Simmons was
doing or if it was repurposed from one
of the Ramey films I think it was new
yeah there was some little variations on
the line because obviously I mean he has
the same talking points every every
single time but I'm sure he's changed it
to say spider woman's a menace and
um the one at the end he definitely
changed because you mentioned the
Sinister Six cartel which we'll get into
later on but they did have new lines of
dialogue there that hadn't heard before
um so yeah like I said you know this
stuff with like Jefferson Davis's party
where Miles isn't there and they're like
why didn't he come and he's uh that
stuff I was a bit like uh it's it's okay
it's it's doing like your standard
character building stuff
um but in retrospect once the movie had
finished you know at the time I might
not have enjoyed it but thinking back to
it knowing what the ending was with
Gwen's hollock with her father uh and
then you know the whole thing with
Jeffers and like I'm just flicking
through stills of the movie on a copy
that I wouldn't I'm not saying anything
that'll get me in trouble but there's a
great moment where Jefferson holds up a
cup to a mural of his his brother Aaron
um which says you know rest in power and
it's got him spray painted on the wall
and even things like that pay off down
the line when you travel to the the
alternate reality at the end where you
can see that mural's been done up for
Jefferson instead and just thinking back
on it little things like that where I
was like uh this is you know it's not as
good as it could be
that kind of elevated it and obviously
you have the the great scenes mixed in
between that such as Gwen and Miles
sitting upside down on that that
building's Legend just kind of it's very
character building at the start and it's
not as focused on the Multiverse
but then once you're hitting whoever
York
oh crazy because everything just hits
the fan and I think we all knew from the
trailers as well that this was going to
be a massive moment in the film as well
because I tell you what Greg when that
first trailer dropped and it had all
those different Spider-Man in that one
shot
but hanging I just thought you know what
I hate this job I'm gonna have to break
down all of these but seeing it not
having to break it down brilliant
um and then obviously you lead into the
the cameos and the cells and there was
so many my favorite one there you
obviously had the PS4 Spider-Man but
there was a little green Sprite 8-bit
figure next to him and that was the
Green Goblin on the Atari 2600.
yeah just seeing that I was like they've
put so much effort into this and then
they obviously pay that off with the
Donald Glover
appearance which I'm starting to really
like the live action mixing with this
stuff and we'll we'll talk in a bit
about what we think they could do after
beyond the spider verse
but I think it worked really well just
seeing you know Mrs Chen was obviously
live action
Donald Glover as well one of the best
Easter eggs ever
yeah I thought that Donald Glover one
was a fan that was the one that I was
audibly like oh [__] I mean it works for
even for people who don't even realize
how big of an Easter egg that is yeah
you know because you're like it's Donald
Glover you know even if you have no idea
if you've completely forgot even who he
was in Spider-Man homecoming to say the
leases that's not even where it started
obviously uh but if if you just like
know like Childish Gambino or Donald
Glover it's already exciting enough as
it is just just to see him there but for
the Spider-Man fans who have followed
this journey for for years when it's
like you know there's a time where
Donald Glover came across like just he
was much younger and he came across kind
of like a a nerdier dorkier dude and now
he's like really cool with his beard and
all that [__] uh so to see like the
evolution but to hone in on like that
Donald Glover love but then all the
tying in with and I believe you did
cover it in your video about like tying
in with with like community and he was
the inspiration for miles and so he was
like miles is Donald Glover by proxy in
a lot of ways you know like it's so it's
so cool and then how he was supposed he
could have been Prowler in the big in
the MCU it's there's still a scenario
where he could end up being the prowler
and the MCU if they wanted to
um but I'm happy that they they got that
in there and it would be cool one day if
Donald Glover was able to actually be a
little more creatively involved I do
have a question
um but I'm wondering from your
experience with the movie because
because I did have some pacing issues
when I was first watching it and I and
for me it was coming from
it was coming from the fact that there
was you would get like a scene with the
spot and it was so kinetic and so funny
and so energetic and they would really
slow it down and I wasn't sure if that
was like my own personal thing where I
was like I'm just recalibrating my brain
and heart right now because I had such a
high and now I'm like oh I gotta really
go to the drama now
and then for you it seemed like you had
some of that effect of and you can
correct me if I'm wrong that you would
you've been told by everyone just how
it's like the greatest freaking thing in
the world so yeah you just kept you kind
of were like okay One's Gonna Be that
great thing that everyone kept telling
me about and I'm like 10 minutes in it's
still not great it's still not great
because I've I've had that for sure
where people have like told me how great
it is and I just keep looking out for it
and then I'm fighting stuff that I'm not
finding super great so then um it's kind
of going down in my book because of that
level of hype was that was that kind of
playing into your your feelings when you
were watching it yeah I just those early
scenes were good but they felt like they
were sort of very in line with what we'd
already seen in the first film and there
were some different animation Styles
sure like the vulture being in
Renaissance pain and stuff like that uh
sorry like it was more like based on a
Leonardo da Vinci's sketch really when
and because obviously Leonardo drew the
invented the helicopter they say um
because he drew wanted a bit of paper so
that I could see that and it was good
but it wasn't really you know building
like going beyond that first film in
terms of the animation and the the style
and just how Connecticut was there were
some parts like where the spots sort of
popping in and out of places and that's
really good
um but then there were more kind of
subdued scenes and I felt they went on
for quite a while like the party scene
on the roof and then when miles was
talking with his mother when Gwen runs
off and you know I thought that was good
but when you kind of have your
expectations set as this is just crazy
this is gonna be kinetic Dynamic all
over the place in terms of animation and
you've got scenes that are very low key
not much really going on in terms of um
you know
explosiveness they don't feel like
they're vibrant and popping off the
screen and there was quite a lot of
those scenes early on like in the school
and stuff like that and I was kind of
thinking yeah when's this gonna get
crazy and then it gets crazy but yeah
they're just that that those early
couple of scenes
on a second viewing I really did like
them but in terms it's it's always the
case with these films as well where you
get you know movie studios nowadays they
let social media reactions go quite
early so you see those and that builds
your anticipation for a film which can
be good but it can also be detrimental
to it which I think happened yet had I
not known
um I might not have been as bad on that
First Act but
like I said they redeem it all in the
second and third act and retroactively
make those early acts better because I
can kind of breathe a sigh of relief now
and be like well I know something that's
crazy coming instead of being like how I
was at the cinema which is like is this
all it's gonna be is this as crazy as it
gets yeah yes out of the out of the new
Spider-Man's who was your favorite that
you I mean like the main new Spidermans
I mean somebody to choose from you know
like spider Punk Spiderman India spider
Punk spider Punk obviously he's British
got punk at you you know the guy and I
just love how Daniel kaluya there's a
lot of things I could tell that
Americans wouldn't get
and just because the accent was so hard
to understand it was even hard for me to
understand sometimes
um they did a great thing and I don't
know if this was intentional but when
he's first introduced in mumbatin when
they go to the collider miles says
something like can you guys understand
this guy and I'm sure that all of Daniel
caluia's lines at that point were
purposely like I couldn't understand
them yes I don't think Americans could
but even throughout the film it was
constantly like bits where he'd be
saying something and I think I think
there's no way Greg understood that he
ain't getting that Cockney Ramen slang I
I the audience I was with there were
stuff that I definitely missed
um but the audience that I was like he
has that line where
um uh he's when when the when
everything's like um collapsing in on
itself and he goes it's a metaphor for
capitalism
it's such a funny ass boy yeah but I
didn't catch that uh because like half
the theater really laughed and the other
half of us were like what did you say
about my wife was next to me and she she
caught it and she was cracking up and I
was like what yeah okay so yeah
sometimes there are certain lines that
are a little bit harder to catch uh but
yeah I think I I love the animation on
him so much where he even even there's
there's like symbolism to the way he's
animated yeah that feels like the
anarchist Rebel as well like he's just
not as smooth or still it's more like
Jagged and rough uh throughout and it
feels like it's like constantly changing
uh very much resembling him and I think
this movie had a exceptional grip on
that with hopping between the different
mediums like you were talking talking
about with the live action and then
going into the different worlds as well
and being able to carry that over even
down to Gwen's World feeling like how it
looks with her spider Gwen Comics I
think it's really cool how they they did
this melding and one thing that I find
myself in weird defensive nowadays
because I've seen some people say like
it can't be uh the best Spider-Man movie
because it's not live action it's
animated and I think it's a silly
argument and and I wonder if that some
people say that because perhaps they
feel that because it's animated there's
a lack of tangibility for them which I
don't feel that way but that's like the
one reasoning I could find behind it
uh to me though the the animation is the
only way you can make this movie this
Spider-Man is an animation you can't
make this in live action you just simply
cannot do it and the voice is part of
the voice is the animation and so to me
I'm like no I would totally freaking
compare this to Spider-Man no way home I
would compare to Spider-Man 2 from
Samurai man why not
um when I'm putting it up against the
other Spider-Man movies and uh I do
think that maybe the first movie had a
smoother
because the first movie doesn't have
like just crazy kinetic energy and then
we're really slowing it down there was
more of a gradual build in the first one
which allowed you to get into the
craziness so I think the first movie has
that but for me do you do you know where
you would put this
um between the Spider-Man movies I don't
know if you'd like or at least between
you're looking more than into the
spider-verse I don't know where you'd
rank it
yeah I like it more than into the
spider-verse
um I did say in my review that I know
I'll have recency biased on it so I
don't want to because I said like no way
home was my favorite Spider-Man movie
and then it's gone back to Spider-Man 2
slash into the spider-verse so I don't
want but I mean it's up there it's
top three or four easily
um and you're right you're completely
right about it being you couldn't pull
this off in live action the animation
style it adds an extra layer to
everything like you were talking before
about spider Punk being you know I I can
see the Sex Pistols album cover in his
design there's bit to a turns like black
and white and it looks like how the
queen appears on God Save the Queen and
there's just little things like that
um where they've clearly researched and
went over so many little things that not
everyone's gonna get but it just builds
upon the character and it adds an extra
layer to it I think when he was telling
his backstory as well it was like
it was using montages and so on
um
and it just worked so well like little
references that not everyone's gonna get
but you can't do that in live action
because you're you're taking animation
Styles and so on and even just for the
amount of action that happens in it I
think would be very difficult to pull up
in live action you can pull off the
party scenes yeah no problem but that
speeding train scene where there's
hundreds of different Spider-Man all
piled on top of each other chasing after
Miles when he's swinging through all the
archways and stuff and there's T-Rexes
popping up and so on you couldn't do
that in live action I don't think uh or
if you did it would look stupid it would
look too unrealistic and you would lose
the the the authenticity of the film
um so yeah I I think you just
this shows why animation is as valuable
as live action is because they've just
done incredible things with it it's like
when you see really good stop-motion
yeah you the work you can see it comes
Acro off the screen how much work's gone
into this and
to devalue it by saying oh well it's not
live action I think that shows you're
just ignorant and yeah you need to watch
more animation yeah it might be harder
to put it together because it's
animation too actually yeah yeah like
you have to you've got something yeah
you've got to design so much stuff and
there's things that you think wouldn't
work like different animation Styles in
the same scene and stuff like I never
thought they could do live action
alongside this uh but they still do and
they pull it off and there's so many
things that shouldn't really work yeah
uh but the fact that they somehow bring
it all together it's incredible it's
it's like it's like when Who Framed
Roger Rabbit came out you know what I
mean it's that level of taking things to
the next point where you can see how
stuff's progressing and you can show
this on its own to someone who isn't
really a fan of superhero movies or
might not be a fan of animated movies
and they'll be able to find stuff in it
they can appreciate yeah there's a lot
of live action especially when you're
like pulling over footage from the older
like Spider-Man movies like Andrew
Garfield's uh alcohol yeah Stacy death
moment and stuff yeah it's got heart
yeah it's got hot it's got really good
characters in it
um Miguel O'Hara he was who I was going
to talk about next
how do you think they utilized him
obviously the spot you know I thought
that they did a lot with his spot as
well the spot's been a very goofy comic
book film I've actually got the first
issue that he ever appeared in really
um and I want to sell it now get rid of
it could be with Millions but yeah I
thought he was a good villain but he
wasn't the person who was really getting
my heart racing
um obviously towards the end when he
turns all black with the little white
dots on and he appears in Miles as well
I thought oh crap this is big but Miguel
as a villain I thought worked really
well I think the spot will be the beyond
the spider verse main villain uh you
think I feel like yeah I think he'll be
the the main villain there I feel like
they'll probably have some type of
resolve with when it comes to Miguel
because we see with Gwen that after
Captain Stacy her dad doesn't
um like there's no what's the
ramification called when the when it
happens in Spiderman India's world after
Captain yeah some Quantum uh
yeah but the Canon event doesn't feel
disrupted it doesn't look like it's been
disrupted after uh Stacy decides to not
wear the badge anymore
um so I think there'll be some type of
resolve with Miguel and them because
what I loved what they did with Miguel's
they didn't paint him as a full-on
villain in this movie
and he's he is antagonistic he is a he
is a threat but what this movie I
thought did exceptionally well one of my
favorite things that if you can do this
especially in a Sci-Fi discussion where
it's like this is not real but I'm so
believing this argument and this
conversation like I I liken it to in
Jurassic Park when Jeff Goldblum and Dr
Hammond are arguing over if they should
have created the park or not if they
should have created the dinosaurs and
the way they have miles and Miguel
arguing with each other about you know
miles wants to leave and save his dad
and that he has his information and
Miguel's obviously very much opposed to
it and he's convinced everyone else too
that these Canon events are necessary
and so you have this like looming
dejected energy from all the spider
people who some of them like Gwen who
have just decided to accept yeah we're
I'm just waiting for my dad to
eventually die it's really tragic it's
really Bleak actually and I thought the
debate was so well done because
obviously I'm on Miles aside obviously
I'm there with Miles like yeah I want
you to save your dad of course and
you're you're our hero and then I would
have the thoughts of
but what if Miguel was right like what
if Miguel yeah maybe Miguel's just being
like he's got to be a hard ass about it
because this is such a weight to bear
and he's and he's got to be Stern and
disciplined but what if he is the one
who's right in Jefferson does have to
die like what if what if my saving
Jefferson a more goes wrong because he's
great at being ruthless and he says some
words that really cut to the core like
when he is ripping into miles on that
train you know saying like you were not
you're abnormal you were not meant to be
like the way he says it is pretty much
saying like you shouldn't even exist in
such a like you you don't matter you're
you're you rob someone else of something
like he he has ways of just being so
insulting
and then you think about some of the
things he's trying to do and you're like
ah but
he might be right there like he might be
right in what he's setting out to do it
and so I think they illustrate such a
fantastic debate whereas spot is a
little more yeah no pun intended he's
very much black and white about the
whole thing you know like I'm just gonna
Dominate and kill and stuff whereas
Miguel at least has that objective that
is really rooted in Saving and
preserving the Multiverse you know so I
I feel there's more going on with Miguel
than he lets on I kind of feel like
there's yeah I don't think we got the
full story with the world ending thing
um because you know miles is an anomaly
I've had so I've had to re-record me
saying an anomaly so many times over the
last week I've just been messing it up
so much uh so miles is an anomaly I got
it uh and his will didn't change or
alter an end and which he admits to
there he obviously had lots of different
Canon events changing in that world as
well
um he saves Spider-Man
India's the Police
Inspector I think they say it's over
there someone will let me know Emma
they've got a different obviously we use
the the term inspector in the UK but uh
I forgot exactly which one is in India
anyway they saved that and obviously
they show they can save that world
the captain Stacy thing happens he
doesn't uh nothing you know the world
doesn't end there and I think that
they're just kind of getting Miguel's
got things in place to basically shut
these black holes down before things get
too crazy but they might not even get
crazy you know what I mean it might just
be all an act and he might not be
telling us the whole truth and my editor
Matt is so switched on to Comics he was
saying the entire time he was thinking
that this is a character who's actually
called maulin from the spider-verse uh
story so what it is is there's vampires
I'm butchering this
um so there's vampires there's a vampire
called maulin who feasts him and his
other people I Feast on the spider verse
um and webs and stuff oh yeah and stuff
and their plan was to bring together all
the different spider people from across
the Multiverse and then eat them yeah so
yeah I've butchered that story it's
probably not right uh I need to reread
it my memory is terrible but yeah that
would be a good little twist and they
even look a bit similar so maybe it's
something like that yeah
for Madame Webb at one point I remember
that yeah he's he's also stepped in the
place of that other spider 2099
so we were thinking that he might have
taken over his place and just be
masquerading as him
Spiderman powers can they do that
what's a movie Greg it's not none of
it's real so they can do whatever they
need the writer to do what you mean
they're all on strike so they can't
change it yeah
love that train bit and when everything
hits the fan and then you have the Peter
B Parker this was one of the criticisms
that my friend bamalam had he was saying
you know Peter B Parker not really
that necessary to the plot and that they
maybe should have just brought him in at
the end when Gwen was recruiting it when
Gwen was the cottonmouth you know what
I'm saying Gwen was recruiting everyone
at the end right and they should have
just brought him in there which you know
what when I was doing my breakdown
realized at the end that I hadn't even
mentioned Peter B Parker at any point in
the breakdown up until that final scene
when I talked about who was with Gwen
oh really it didn't really I didn't even
miss him like that that was interesting
compared to into the spider-verse
because it was my first time seeing
miles and and then and then you know you
see like there's a Peter Parker that's
advertising the trailer so I was like I
wonder where Peter Park was like I was I
was anxious to see Peter Parker the
first time I saw him yeah spider person
of course I loved the dynamic between
like you don't have any Dynamic like
that that exists here but the one that
they have with Miles and Peter B Parker
and into the spider-verse
um but yeah I wasn't even thinking about
Peter B Parker until he showed up that I
was like yeah oh yeah Parker which to me
which uh I think speaks good volumes to
the evolution of this because
I don't I I cared I was significantly
more emotionally I like miles a lot in
the first one I really did uh I was
significantly more emotionally invested
because he's just more fleshed out he's
got more of a character Journey
personally it's something that's more
unique as well in this one uh so I
really liked him a lot but yeah Peter B
Parker was this is kind of it was like
extra dumb to me at certain points
that's what I don't know certain
thoughts he's like he's such a shitty
parent like he's such a terrible parent
how dumb he was yeah great taking a kid
that I don't know if I would not on top
of a speeding training definitely get in
trouble but I know of course
yeah after that train scene it it's
revealed you know miles says LED
everyone away from the base so that he
can go back there I was like yes
brilliant it's genius he electrocutes uh
Miguel leaps off the train
disappears goes invisible
crazy loved it the entire scene we're
doing a perfect scene breakdown on that
scene alone talking about how
thematically it lines up with the film
because obviously you have these um
adults throughout the film that are
constantly telling miles like what he
has to be he's and then his teacher at
the start gives him a blank piece of
paper and says I don't know your story
and the film is very much about you know
his parents telling him he has to act a
certain way the spot telling him he has
to act a certain way Gwen's saying you
can't come with me Miguel's saying you
you're an anomaly uh we don't want you
as part of our society you you were
never meant to be and that's very much
the moment where the dynamic switches
and he gets to choose what he wants to
be and he is gonna save his dad he
doesn't care about all those you know
the the personification of peer pressure
I called it which is when all the
Spider-Man appear around him you've got
Josh Keaton Spectacular Spider-Man being
like you've got to let your dad die mate
he's
Go Gotta progress the plot gotta keep
selling Comics um
so that's the moment where he shocks it
and shows that you know this isn't this
is Miles and that is the thing with
miles in general like you'll still see
it today where lots of people argue that
Miles isn't his own character and um
that is just always in Spider-Man's
Shadow but he and that happened when he
was created as well people were
demanding that like Brian Michael Bendis
bring back Peter Parker as the main
Spider-Man but he's he's very much
justifying that he is a Spider-Man
that's gonna stick around you should
follow him and this is why he can do
things differently he doesn't have to
stick to the story we've heard hundreds
and hundreds and hundreds of times
before they they make it clear in the
movie this is something that every
Spider-Man has to go through so get used
to hearing this same old story and Mars
is going against that in that moment
where it all builds to that I think is
absolutely incredible and then what he
does is he goes back to the machine
because he doesn't have a way to
actually travel through the Multiverse
he's got that gas pass he doesn't
actually have one of those bands where
he he can do it and he gets back to the
machine and goes we're gonna tell you it
scansi DNA and finds out what Universe
you're from and then sends you back
there and the big twist is that because
the spider bit him
uh from Earth 42 that his DNA is
actually now containing stuff from Earth
42 so that's where he's sent back and
I'm sure there's actually if you
re-watch the movie when the spot's
telling the origins of the spider you
can catch a little the back of miles's
head with braids in it really great
seeing that um
so yeah what was the The Twist like how
did he react at what point did you
realize because I'll tell you when I
realized pretty early on when he was in
the room and he had a green coat on with
a purple hoodie and Rio had green eyes
and I was like your eyes have changed
color okay and that he's wearing the
prowler's colors as well I did not
notice it with that
um I think though I think that whole
sequence you're talking about is truly
brilliant like the entire when Miguel is
explaining how all these Canon events
work
and even down to when he called tells
him how he's anomaly
and just the whole sequence as well with
him running away from the Spider-Man
because you're absolutely right that he
comes into his own identity in this
movie even more so that's what I mean
like oh I didn't even miss Peter B
Parker whatsoever I just wanted miles's
Journey
and like the sequence of him having to
outwit and outmaneuver his way away from
a bunch of Spider-Man
was
nothing short of exhilarating to me it
was so exciting uh from beginning
because that you've seen Spider-Man go
up against so many villains but you
haven't seen him go up against a bunch
of versions of himself like working
together with them we've seen a bunch of
but he's in full-on versus Escape mode
and I thought that was so so freaking
exciting and I think the writing of it
is great because you know when Miguel's
on the train because we're talking about
that one sequence when you find out that
twist Miguel's on the train and he is
saying you know you weren't supposed to
yeah he is that is that the same one he
tells him that Owen saw the one time
that that's the scene when he says like
someone someone else
there's a world that exists without a
Spider-Man because of him yeah in the
moment I was just I was so focused on
how and I think a lot of us were I was
so focused on how this is affecting
Miguel's emotions on what you're doing
to this kid right now and how you're
making him feel worthless and
undeserving
that that was where I wasn't even
thinking about well I wonder what that
world is where there's no Spiderman like
I had no thoughts about that I was so
focused on Miguel's emotions
yeah
it could be that I was I was so focused
on what Miguel was experiencing in the
and the the core while they were
delivering important ass Exposition at
the same time and to me that's like
brilliant writing because you're so
wrapped up in the emotional investment
so when they do get to the scene
um with the mom it was right away when
she says who's Spider-Man and because a
lot of us I heard a lot of people in the
crowd going what and once I heard people
going what that's immediately when I was
like I think I was I was very audible
during the I normally try to as much as
I do reactions on this on my channel I
try to reserve myself in an actual
theater but I was very audible during
this experience and I did go oh always
in the other you're just centered out
yeah I was like he's in the wrong
Universe like and I thought that was a
brilliant twist uh leading to some very
ominous moments as well because it
should be something that
it's I just love the complex it's the
movie's so complex in all the right ways
it's com there's so much happening but
it's complex in in every way that's a
compliment like he's seen his uncle
Aaron you've got these Vibes of that's
his uncle Aaron you know he misses him
he loves him but this is also very
threatening and and Incredibly menacing
at the same time when he is popping in
there and and of course as the revealing
of the world this world is dad's dead
it's I I think that whole reveal and the
finale moment was excellent because
some people I've heard have said that
they don't they did it I've heard it
expressed quite a bit more so than ever
now that they're unsatisfied with that
it ends on such a cliffhanger that they
feel like there's not a proper
conclusion but I feel like the proper
conclusion hey he does Miguel does have
his Arc he does have his character Arc
but I think it really comes with Gwen is
that's the complete so there's a reason
the movie starts off with her and then
it ends with her as well as as well
because that's this movie is just as
much hers and that's where the complete
character art comes into to the story so
the whole part two of it being of the
completion is with her but then yeah the
completion for miles's story will come
in the form of beyond the spider verse I
think
definitely no 100 agree uh I don't know
why people complain about films ending
on cliffhanger's a lot of the time as
well when Infinity War released I tell
you what there was a guy who I used to
work with actually rang me up angry
after it said what the hell is that
about what they've just ended it when
everyone's dead I was like well they're
making another movie mate you just need
to chill it's coming but it's you know
it's Empire Strikes Back you know I mean
that they're doing the the second film
Cliffhanger uh I thought it was great
and I thought they're basically silenced
of the Lambs the finals that that scene
with um
miles's mother because what I mean by
silenced of the Lambs is you have one
scene going on somewhere they set it up
so it looks like another scene's
happening at the same place and then you
realize that the two different scenes
are at different locations so clarison
Silence of the Lambs you've got the SWAT
team Harry says go and investigating
stuff you've got the SWAT team going to
Buffalo Bill's house you cut to the
inside you hear the door ringing the
SWAT team's outside ringing the door
blah blah blah Buffalo Bill finally goes
upstairs they cut it so it looks like
the SWAT team standing outside and then
he opens the door and Clarice is there
now how they do it in across the spider
verse is that they have miles telling
his mother Miguel's you know like we're
gonna get to his house Gwen swings
outside of it she starts looking in the
window peeking around to see and you
think that you're gonna see them having
the conversation and then that's when
you realize that oh these are the same
location but in two different universes
really good
then notice you have uncle Aaron and all
the Venom learning that his dad's dead
uh when you see the mural on the wall
and then you're kind of wondering you
know they keep talking about miles and
giving little hints towards him Aaron's
like come on we're going to be late
we've got a job tonight uh and then yeah
it's a fan yeah miles gets knocked out
wakes up on the punching bag just like
how Peter B Parker did in that first
film uh he's talking to Aaron you're
kind of getting the impression that
Aaron's the prowler and then when he
punches the punching bag and it just
like explodes out the back I was
thinking has he just punched miles's
head off but no the something drops down
from the Shadows Prowler looking bad guy
then it all the masks and he goes
something like my name is Miles Morales
he says it more spanishly I'll get in
trouble for saying spanishly but you
know what I mean I'm trying to apologize
for my my use of terminology there but
he's got more of a Spanish accent which
calls back to those teacher
bits at the start when he was failing
Spanish but he was you know that's
obviously because his dad died and he
got more of an influence from his mother
on the Spanish side of stuff his little
touches like that really really well
thought out
and I think he's going to be the villain
of the next film
I think you're gonna start off with
Miles escaping the punching bag
uh they're going to have a big chase you
know Aaron's just become aware that his
brother's Alive In Another Universe and
I was thinking about this more and more
we are I am dropping a predictions video
very soon but the more I thought about
it Aaron in the first movie and
Jefferson didn't really make up
um so obviously they went their separate
ways and then Aaron died now in this
alternate universe you've got something
on the opposite side of it where Aaron
and Jefferson probably did make up and
then Jefferson died so you've got these
two characters from across the
Multiverse and someone mentioned it in a
comment I can't remember who it is I do
shout you out in the video though so
keep an eye out for that but they said
that they think Jefferson's gonna
sacrifice himself in the other Universe
to save
oh sorry Aaron's gonna sacrifice himself
in the other Universe to save Jefferson
and that'll be him kind of redeeming it
and then they'll they'll also get that
moment where the the two meet in the
like well in my universe you died and we
never got to say how much we loved each
other and it's like I love you brother
say I love you too brother then he
sacrifices himself
so I think that the miles we see at the
end is gonna go to the other universe so
parallel miles will I think Gwen's gonna
show up with all the spider buddies and
they've all got bands and also they can
travel the Multiverse they're gonna show
up to rescue miles and that's when
Prowler miles is gonna get his hand on
one of the bands that allows you to
travel through the Multiverse and then
he's gonna go to the
the Jefferson first we'll call it and
then he to see his dad basically because
he's obviously lost his dad he's went
down a really dark path through losing
him so I think he'll want to go there
and he might end up fighting the spot to
save
miles's dad none of your story plot
ideas or anything to do with the spot
though you don't really feel like the
spot's gonna happen anymore ramification
I think Miguel is going to fight the
spot but Miguel is in a precarious
situation now talk about this in the
theories video because
obviously the spot's getting more and
more powerful he's going down diff he's
going throughout the Multiverse wrecking
things completely destroying stuff he
has the power to bring the entire
Multiverse down so Miguel saw all the
mall and theories right well keep it
like it's just Miguel keep it simple
Miguel can either allow this spot to
continue and just keep going kill
Jefferson and probably go off and
destroy the rest of the Multiverse or he
can stop the spot but in doing that it
will save Jefferson which will go
against his entire ideology of Canon
events have to happen so Miguel is in a
lose-lose situation as well they've got
a lot of things they can do in this next
film
so I think yeah Miguel's obviously
Miguel we know Miguel's near where the
spots just arrived at because they were
staking out miles's place so I think
they're gonna you know in one University
gonna have miles going against Perler
miles uh and then in this other Universe
you're gonna have Miguel going against
the spot and then they're gonna all
convene
at maybe the center of the Multiverse
where every reality is coming together
I kind of feel like
I wonder if it might become a little
more simplified than that I love I love
where you're going with the idea of
Jefferson what's great about this is you
really can't
a lot of times you can go well I'm
definitely going to go down this path
you really can't
no speak fully certain which path it's
gonna go down especially with the movie
This sequel which had so many surprises
I don't think anyone predicted any of
this of what what would happen in this
movie especially when it's like last
half hour because it's crazy when you
look back on it how the trailers the
especially the official trailer it does
show you a lot of the plot technically
right down to like you know Miguel and
miles on the train and and the the
confrontation they're having there and
him saying like I'm sick of people
timing what I should be so they do show
you a decent amount in that official
trailer yet uh it's still such an
unpredictable film
and here I'm like okay there could also
be a very simple way it'll concludes you
know maybe there is a resolve
um between like let's say Miguel's just
Miguel and there ends up being a resolve
there and everyone has to somehow unite
together to take down spot it can be
something like as simplistic as that
because you know I don't know how Miguel
could take down spot just alone on his
own because spot just seems like
Society
yeah that's true he could he could still
it's like
what would they do though you know to do
it just go crazy with the animation get
everyone in just the surprise
because they want that crazy animation
scene yeah yeah
I loved spot a lot
um I I you you have more of an emotional
I don't know preconceived notion of how
it would all go down but did you did you
personally like him I thought he was
great because yeah
especially when you can take a vill a
villain who starts off as like villain
of the week and it's just kind of goofy
and then watch as he progresses into
something truly terrifying
without it being silly it's it's
actually scary and I feel like in live
action it would come across silly but
here it's actually scary when he does
become this this dark demonic void void
and using him as a as a way to have fun
with going into the different
multiverses as well and having him be
having him be a Ville because a lot of
the you know the Spider-Man villains
part of the joke is how a lot of them
are like scientists turn bad who have a
relationship prior with with Peter
Parker usually you know in some regard
and to have it be something where it is
a specific Vendetta with Spider-Man and
how you know this version of my this
miles is is actually kind of partially
responsible for how he came to be and
also telling it in this like body horror
tale you do feel like there's a sense of
tragedy to him that you are kind of
laughing at
so watching his progression on top of
that too the music that they compliment
him with I just feel like this movie is
so that like it is the most it is the
best Spider-Man movie oh it is
amazing yes I love this spot in it I
think his arc's really good he starts
off as quite I mean this is a super
villain origin story as well this entire
Trilogy because when you find out how
you know he ties in with that first film
you're watching you know two people in
this universe rising up against each
other he keeps going on about how he's
miles of Nemesis and yeah he sort of is
in a way because he he obviously caused
the thing that created him and with the
spider bite and then miles created the
spot by intervening so they've got this
re you know they are tied together
really nicely
um and they see him go from this goofy
guy robbing ATMs I won't say ATM machine
I'll say ATMs to go from that to what he
is at the end where he's just like this
drops down in the me yeah
so good yeah oh my God and you said the
ATM because it's Spider-Man India and I
loved him I love I did not see I saw
that they released a promo when I was
doing my edit for our review I saw that
they released a promo that introduces
him and I did not watch that uh prior to
seeing it so I had no idea like how
Spider-Man India would be and I thought
he was such a wonderful breath of fresh
air because so much of Spider-Man comes
with like the responsibility you know
yeah and the tragicness the weight of
being Spider-Man and for him to just
like swing onto the scene and be like
being Spider-Man's easy like yeah how
fun it would be to be Spider-Man and and
then even like uh the India type world
that they have there and then shouting
it out making making fun but also
highlighting and I thought was was an
absolute delight and that was a
character that I didn't have like
expectations necessarily but that had
that effect of of when you like see
Spider-Man Noir in the first one or
something like that you know like those
they had they introduced these
characters that make you
because they don't advertise like like
Spider-Man Noir and um I'm totally blank
on his name which one's John mullaney's
again in the first one spider ham
goddamn yeah and like spider ham in the
first one they don't have any of them
here in this film and they were such a
highlight of the first one
and yet they give you these new ones and
so I think this movie it really does
excel at making you so invested in even
the new characters and loving them that
you're not even missing some of the
people who were not present you know and
a lot of times that's a sequel problem a
sequel issue is it's missing the
presence of this you can feel that this
person is missing you could feel the air
of this like the missing presence of
this individual and this movie doesn't
suffer from that
at all uh I I think it's probably one of
the best sequels that's ever been done
yeah what'd you think of Jessica Drew
though I don't hear enough people talk
about her yeah I mean she was all right
she was kind of like I don't know yeah I
thought she was fine she didn't really
have much she sort of like Gwen's mother
really because obviously Gwen doesn't
have a mother it's not that we met
um I'm not sure how the the workings of
that Universe are uh but yeah she kind
of acted as that you know being like a
guiding figure for her and then when
she's doing stuff she shouldn't be she
gets it because she understands love
She's sort of the opposite to miles's
Mother almost who you know she's trying
to be strict tell Gwen how to act but
when she sees he you know they really
like each other she's willing to turn a
blind eye to it
um so yeah I mean I thought she was all
right I wasn't Blown Away by it to be
honest uh what do you thinking about uh
all the parenting themes that were this
movie's laced littered yeah
throughout even right down to Jessica
Drew getting being pregnant yeah being
pregnant yeah
yeah and it works well because you're
seeing the relationship from both sides
so you you're getting really well
developed parents but you're also
getting really well developed children
and having to deal with their parents
who are trying to look after them but
obviously they have these incredible
abilities you've got plb Parker who's
repairing and Miguel who's obviously
lost his family lots of different themes
um and obviously miles as well you see
what what effect it has you know that
they constantly talk about I'm sure
spider Punk says at one point oh you
must have a nice family something like
that he's like yeah they're okay but
then we see like I think Prowler miles
is going to show miles exactly you know
how good his family are and what would
happen if he didn't have them which I
think is a really great Arc
um so yeah I think that all works well
you know going back to Spider-Man India
I didn't get to talk about them because
you weren't delegating prop being he
didn't even ask me I think one of the
things he shows is that uh the dot how
good the dialogue is this the the so
normally in a in a live action film
obviously when you're on set and you're
interacting with people you can
improvise and throw a little lines here
and there but all of the lines they
would have been written to be recorded
in a recording studio where you're
probably not interacting with all the
other actors as much
um and for them to still have like these
little quips it's written like they're
improvising almost
um and and just having like the little
things like why do they call it chai tea
it's just chai just stuff like that
um
there's so many little bits where they
would have written it but it's delivered
flawlessly I mean we know how difficult
it is reading from a script sometimes
into a mic you sound totally different
your delivery is a lot different uh but
they just nailed it every every aspect
of it really
everything they set out to do they they
did it
they did it stepped up the animation
score was incredible
character development amazing
crazy big twist at the end he nailed it
guys nailed it and we'll love it what'd
you think about
it feels we're like an hour 20 something
minutes into here but I do want to know
I'm gonna redelegate what you think
about we you didn't really touch on Gwen
personally in this uh discussion so far
I thought Gwen was great really really
I've always yeah I've always thought
Gwen's a great character in these films
um yeah she's actually got stuff to do
you know Gwen Stacy when when you're
dealing with Gwen Stacy it's very easy
to fall into under using that character
and killing her off before
some you actually get to developer I
don't know if you guys have read the
Ultimate Spider-Man run but I tell you
what the way they handled Gwen Stacy in
that towards especially towards the end
with her death I was fuming I was like
nah I love this comic so far but the way
they handle her death and that is kind
of just
so bad it she doesn't get a chance to
get properly developed and just as
you're really getting attached to her
they just kill around the blue and it's
not with all Brooklyn Bridge thing
um a clone of Peter that's becoming
Carnage she goes home one night because
she's living with Peter and Aunt May she
goes home one night and he's there
instead he just kills her and that's it
uh Shea doesn't even see it or anything
it's it's really weirdly handled
um and you can run into the pitfall with
Gwen Stacy you know Amazing Spider-Man
say whatever you want about those films
but they handled the Gwen stuff really
well the relationship in this film as
well Sony know what they're doing when
it comes to Gwen she's a really um
fleshed out character
they really know you can't underscore
that enough they know how to handle it
yeah she she's great and uh you you know
you you feel a relationship between her
and Miles yeah I put her in miles above
Peter Parker
Gwen you know what I mean like Gwen and
Peter Parker are the classic tragic
couple but I put miles in Gwen above
them
it was make immediately I was going back
as you're talking about Gwen it was
immediately making me go to one of my
favorite
um adaptations
of Gwen was actually her relationship
with Peter Parker in The Spectacular
Spider-Man show did you did you see
Spectacular Spider-Man
bits of it yeah
I mean I forget everything that I don't
need to remember as soon as it's over I
know exactly what movie did we watch
yeah well I watched a movie the other
week
um fast X knew at the time couldn't tell
you what the hell happened in and out no
idea if you asked me a question about
that film
uh no idea what happened to it what's
the pressure with trailer reactions that
I struggle with I'm like oh [__] yeah
what happened but Spectacular Spider-Man
you know like I love the Donald Glover
Cameo
um and I really I really think the way
how they in this show they do a great
parallel between the kind of unique
dynamic because you know like Mary Jane
is you know hot and [__] or uh you have
Gwen who's a nerd as well and I think
Spectacular Spider-Man show really
nailed that and Spectacular Spider-Man
I've seen the whole thing
and that to me was a moment on screen
that that really meant a lot to me it
meant more to me than the Donald Glover
one because I love Spectacular
Spider-Man show I got the DVDs of it I
was given to me by my friend Aaron and I
did not I was not told that it just
suddenly stopped uh yeah so I didn't
have the feeling of wow what a great
season two finale like I really I like
it more than the 90s show it's such a
great season two finale can't wait to
watch the next one I was trying to find
it I was like what it just so for me
that was a cameo that spoke volumes
um and especially like really give like
they have the Spider-Man PS4 Cameo or
you're low inthology does have a line
but it's kind of obscured whereas they
really let uh Spectacular Spider-Man
actually be front and center for just a
few seconds and and say some poignant
[__] and so that was a cameo that really
spoke a lot to me
yeah yeah it's nice seeing them just the
care they put into the film like there's
so many little things like even the
first film when they had the Spider-Man
ice Lolly just a little stupid throwaway
meme stuff and I remember us all going
wild because of the pointing meme at the
end
um but I mean obviously the the amount
deep layered cuts they have here like
Mysterio from spider-ham's Universe just
a Mysterio that's a moose just little
things like that brilliant Rhino and
he's a rhino
yeah brilliant absolutely you know the
movie is effective too when they show
the spider Point meme in the trailer
yeah and then when it comes up it's
still it's funny as hell and exciting
what they do because you're in the
middle of like
it's the best tension and release moment
of the film because you're is so intense
what's happening and then go get
Spider-Man and they cut to it and you
did it go like everyone clapped in my in
my screening when I watched it like
everyone even though you see it in the
trailer
they still somehow it just generates so
much like it pulls you in so much you're
not even thinking about that coming up
and then when it happens yeah it still
surprises you yeah I love it and you
know you know what else it does that not
a lot of other comic book movies don't
do no post-credits scene not needed I
mean just to be continued beyond the
spider verse
so and even
I'll say like when it goes even though
the title was revealed for beyond the
spider verse it just hits so much
different when they when they show it
afterwards yeah the thoughts associated
with it and the anticipation
of wow like what is what is what is the
implications of that now you know before
you're like across the spider-verse
beyond the spider verse okay we got two
title reveals I wonder what it means but
then it turns into what is this gonna be
the energy on it it gets you excited in
a whole different way than when you
first heard it
well that takes us into our final topic
which is beyond the spider verse is
we've got rumors now that miles is going
to be getting a live-action film Gwen's
gonna be getting a live action film as
well apparently they're going to be
going beyond the spider verse does that
mean the characters are gonna go into
the MCU and live action
uh these characters I hope not I I I
don't know I don't want these guys to
you you I don't want these um the
animated versions like to translate to
become live action you want another
miles origin story
I mean the smile's origin is so specific
to the spider-verse isn't it isn't that
true you know like it's not
like the Spiderman the miles
introduction I if I'm recalling
correctly my miles introduction is
actually the PS4 game if I'm not
mistaken
um wow Lily uh don't say that on this
podcast on this channel you'll get
really slow at night you're supposed to
have been reading them day one no it was
not man I don't have to be you it's the
reason you do all the Trump
um yeah it's like such a mildest thing
to say this is my I'm I'm Miguel right
now going your Canon moment is to have
red miles straight away back in Ultimate
Spider moment and you're like no I don't
need to be you you chump I I uh yeah
he's got it's so specifically tied to it
and I and I feel like we're so used to
tying these these interpretations over
into specifically spider verse whereas I
think I mean you would have to have some
element of spider-verse especially if
you're doing like a spider Gwen and then
a live action one
but I think you'll be worrying too much
about how it connects to the events of
the animated films that we saw before
where I feel like they could do more of
their own thing if they do a separate
type of just a separate rendition of
them and they let this story conclude
secret was
let's bring it together and see what was
that's what I like to see
miles I'd like to see Miles live action
coming across from this
you know they had the well we're doing
another video keep right that would be
cool that would be keep promoting these
videos I'm doing but we're doing one
about the incursions uh in the MCU and
how that's similar to what's happening
with the stuff in across the
spider-verse and how the Multiverse is
dying everything I see is basically
flagging to me that the Multiverse is
dying it's very fragile
very unstable you do something in
another reality it's gonna cause crap
whether that's going there and living a
life with a family whether that's
dreamwalking with the dark old if you
mess around in another reality it's
gonna cause crap and the fact that all
the heroes are starting to really touch
the Multiverse right now
stuff's gonna come apart and I think
it's all going to culminate in secret
Wars I hope it does I've been rereading
Jonathan Hickman's run
um building up I'm still at the new
Avengers slash Avengers point which is
one book you have the Illuminati
um basically doing less the secret stuff
wiping a raising Captain America's
memory so he doesn't remember that
they've been destroying worlds across
the Multiverse and in the other book
you've got the front facing stuff where
everybody's like yeah we love fighting
baddies it's really great and then that
all builds towards Secret Wars
incredible Rod one of the best runs out
there uh yeah and yeah watching these
movies and reading that alongside I can
see how stuff's starting to slide but we
will see we're getting to the 90 minute
Mark right now and I think we've covered
all the topics that was a lot better
than us that was our best episode ever
and I'm hopefully gonna say that every
single week
and I I have rough time stamps to tell
you later yes
I got Michael on here I got that on here
I got I got Robert on here and uh for
the for the flash don't have Ezra I
specifically made sure not to put Ezra
Miller on my TV yeah I mean when they
can't really have Ezra at the premieres
and doing press screenings it's probably
best to just avoid uh getting Ezra on
board stuff but yeah that concludes his
show if you want to support the channel
um and get some merch out of it we've
got a merch store over at
xeroedition.com you can buy that bat
face t-shirt I've got a secret Invasion
t-shirt coming very soon that you guys
are gonna like The Peacemaker one I wore
on um the first episode or technically
this is the first episode of cross the
spoilers but yeah all the merch do you
want a shirt that says Theory Time Zero
edition.com huge thank you for checking
us out we are now on Apple podcast
Spotify
um Amazon podcasts as well you can
listen to us on the go you can listen to
us on YouTube if you want Audio Only or
you can watch the video along just see
us talking away personally I wouldn't do
that but yeah it's the options there if
you want to do it wherever you get your
podcasts we will be there bringing you
lots of spoilers from across the
spoilerverse huge thank you for checking
us out I've been pulled from heavy
spoilers
he's being Greg from real rejects I
thought he was going to jump in there I
think I know I was like did we have a
little bit of delay of recording like it
might it might just been in to say I'm
Greg yeah
he's Greg over that correct time
um yeah and I hope you guys have enjoyed
it as much as we have been great
speaking to you we'll be back next week
we're still we're still trying to figure
out what day we want to release on
um it's kind of weird
but we'll figure it out see see when
people enjoy it if you can let us know
in the comments below as well
um if you have anything that you you
want to suggest to us we're totally open
just don't say uh end the podcast please
but yeah thanks for checking us out
hopefully there wasn't do much confusion
with the name and we'll see you next
time
ah